yeah I guess he felt like he was
impressing the person that he's he's out
all of the body language is him like
sitting forward and being like Oh my
gosh so fun you mentioned on the date
that could be white no that's because he
felt like he he betrayed him if they
were on a date and it's like and he
comes up he's he it could be I don't
know I don't know man I like you love me
I'm like no no it could be I think if
they assuming that the tax story is is
correct I'm waiting for the confirmation
it's because this guy basically is
admitting to like Global level
international incident malfeasance but
we we you know well we can't find his
LinkedIn page already so I don't know I
did a lot of work trying to find it
right but like it's not obvious he's
obviously clearly proud of like what
position he's in he's willing to talk
about it pretty openly like I'm
surprised that it's not more obvious who
this person is unless Pfizer he's gonna
be like oh we terminated that person
several weeks ago he was talking so a
matter of factly about it like he it was
just it was just rolling off the tongue